This year has been all about the comfy cozies
obviously the sweatshirts and the sweat pants
but we can't forget those feet, Rossi.
Never.
The feet have demanded Crocs.
They've demanded Uggs.
And now Glamor Magazine reports.
The trend that is everywhere.
You're gonna see it, socks and sandals.
Yeah, Drew,
I don't know how I feel about this one.
Really, Rossi?
Yeah, I'm just a firm believer
that I don't like that.
No, is it just because you're like
you've given up on life or it's just not your track.
I just, I went to college.
I remember seeing so many people with socks
and those like, Adidas...
Shower slippers.
Yeah, shower slippers,
at the dining hall
and always being like, I almost can't eat.
I hate that look so much
I love it, Rossi, we differ.
Cause I'll rock a sock in a sandal any day.
Look, that's cute for you.
Maybe, maybe you can pull that off.
I don't know, but I definitely do it.
Okay, Rossi
what, you got?
Now let's move onto something,
no one thinks it's awful puppies, right?
(crowd cheers)
We, around here, we love our dogs
and we have such an intimate bond with them.
And country living reports
a new study that says ancient women may be responsible
for our love of dogs.
Really?
Yeah, researchers
at Washington State University studied 144
ancient societies with dogs
and they found out that it was women
who invited the dogs inside the home.
Back in the day they gave the dogs names, personalized them
gave them a physical affection that we,
I think doggie that we all know and love today.
So, and I thought about that.
It makes sense because you know, my dad was always the one
like bringing a dog home
and then my mom was the one making sure
that we always took care of the dog.
Look, doggie.
Look at you.
Down, down.
Good, doggie.
He does.
He bros like a little tick in the bed and he'll just stay
with you for like 18 hours.
Do you?
Oh yeah.
So you clearly think this story is true.
Well, I do love the fact that women just honestly
they're just...
Sit.
We are unbreakable creatures in that way of like, we
I do think have a tendency to really be caretakers
and have a lot of empathy towards children and animals.
And just kind of like be a little bit of that glue
that holds the home together
while quietly resenting you for not doing your part.
(crowd laughs)
Does that happen in the cave too?
Like, you know, that hide that we all ate tonight.
Well, it needs to leave the cave, put it out in the trash.
Yeah, I think some things never changed, you know
but I also think the study could have like
studied the ancient gay
down the block who had like, like multi poos.
Cause I'm sure he loved his dogs too.
You know, I think you're right about that one, Rossi.
We do agree on that.
A hundred percent.
Speaking of good boys,
have you ever wanted to be a bad boy, Rossi?
Yeah, I'm still holding out hope one day.
I just never want to get in trouble.
So you are a good boy.
Yeah, I know, it's annoying.
I know.
Well, Ink Magazine just actually said
that there are three bad behaviors that psychologists
they are actually really good for you.
So let's see if you do any of these
one is like leaving little, tiny rebellions
like rolling down all your windows and your car.
Oh my God.
And playing
Your music so loud.
That's me
In the future Rossi.
Oh, look at you, you look great Drew.
Oh, here's a little, here's a window.
You look great.
But have you ever done that?
Just like roll the windows down
and just played the music so loud?
All the time.
See you're rebellious.
What about this one?
Getting bored
they say as a little rebellion
it actually make you more creative.
Like it forces the creativity.
Yeah, I remember I was a kid, my mom's.
I said I was bored and she goes, well
that means you're a boring person.
And she said, find something to do.
And you said your signature, I beg your pardon?
I beg your pardon?
I got, I found something to do.
That's what I did.
And the number three thing they say to rebel, swearing
they say it releases anger and it bonds you with friends
and it increases your pain tolerance, which okay.
(soft music)